yeah sure why not is there movies out
there I haven't even reviewed yet but
night-you rockabyebaby or whatever the
hell this let's just do this when the
bough breaks the cradle will fall
alright so when the bough breaks is a
shitty movie starring Morris Chestnut
alright this has got to be the third or
fourth movie where I've been like more
just not was good in that shitty movie
this just got to start making good
movies and good decisions I'm gonna stop
making excuses for him at a point so
basically there's this couple there a
successful couple they want a kid they
can't have a kid so they do this
surrogacy program where someone else
carries their fertilized egg and sperm
makes a baby in the bait you know like
Phoebe did for her brother so they
picked this girl who's sweet and awesome
answered all the right questions
perfectly turns out she's nuts and now
we have a suspense ish movie we don't
it's actually quite a shitty movie that
just it's the road to nowhere it's one
of my colors first of all this movie
could have been fine it could have been
like fatal attraction sure yeah that
would have been cliche as hell that
would have been safe but it would have
been serviceable but this movie tries to
be more than that and just it turns into
a wreck where you don't even know how
you're going down the road to madness
like really alright I feel like I'm
spoiling part of the suspense for its
spoiler alert the movies dog [ __ ]
alright now I'm gonna tell you why it is
gonna tell you the secrets in a movie
that you just should not watch it would
have had an element of suspense if
Morris Chestnut scare achter did
something with this girl you know she
would have been like blooming to tell
your wife but instead no he never does
like he never does anything she starts
flashing her titties Adam he's like this
needs to stop he was like immediately a
pretty responsible ish person he didn't
do anything so there's no real leverage
the real leverage she has over him as I
guess in this movie she can be like huh
I'm gonna keep the baby and you can't
have your baby and that's why he ends up
going along with it and even then having
a law degree but I feel like that's
[ __ ] when you have a friend in this
movie which he does you dug up dirt on
this girl which he did she has a
criminal record she used an alias to
have this procedure she's clearly not
well and she left the dead body of her
boyfriend in her basement I just I feel
like you have enough to be like now
she's not a fit mother I'm gonna head
and take our kid yeah thanks there's no
leverage there's that just took me out
of the movie every
I'm there like she has one hope on oh
she could take our kids like no she
can't again not a lawyer I just feel
like there's enough there to be like no
she's not taking [ __ ] legally speaking
and the road to her trying to seduce the
husband in this movie is so abrupt I
mean she's nice she never really loses
her [ __ ] until like one day she's like
yeah I just kind of want to sit on that
guy's face and then he doesn't
reciprocate and then she'd still kind of
this flirty about it there's nothing
there's no tension the tensions
completely defeated would have been a
cool movie if throughout the movie
you're like is this chick nuts is she
not the movie ruins that early on when
it establishes that she had this
procedure done to scam this couple that
she now kind of likes she did it have to
be hest of her boyfriend who's a
complete scumbag and shows us exactly
what overacting is it's like the
director was like but on your villain
face all the time I'm telling you man it
was so over the top and I really think
anything involving this boyfriend of
this surrogate girl I feel like all of
that was filmed two months ago
yeah like reshoots after the movie
wrapped you take anything and everything
involving this boyfriend out of the
movie people get smarter the movie just
gets better you take the boyfriend out
that means his girl had this procedure
done out of the kindness of her heart
she starts falling for this dude and
just starts going nuts that's better
you take the boyfriend out of the
equation it doesn't spoil the fact that
she is actually nuts trying to scam this
couple it's better you take the
boyfriend out of it she doesn't stab the
boyfriend leave his dead body in her
basement for months as she's living with
the couple now so she's not there but
this is technically their house it
might've been her boyfriend's house but
she still lived there good at the end of
this movie when she calls up the dude
who's the father's like on going into
labor and then she shows up at the
hospital he's like is she here and
they're like who's here no one checked
in but he's like oh where did she go hmm
if he goes on the hunt for her going to
her old house her boyfriend's house and
he finds his body in the basement he's
like oh my gosh my wife's in danger no
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude it's like the
boyfriend was just in the movie just to
have a dead body that he would then go
and find when he makes the completely
illogical decision to go on the wild
goose chase looking for this girl which
he is clearly at his own house ready to
kill his wife because her saying hey I'm
going into labor was just a ploy to get
him away from his wife I'm telling you
man people just got dumber because that
boyfriend was ever in this movie guys in
the end when the bough breaks is a
would-be cliche as a little attraction
asked movie but in the end it's a sloppy
a suspense movie with no suspense
whatsoever this movie is that Scout
leader that took you hiking with no map
no compass now it's lost and you're not
having a good time at all I already said
it once I'll say it again when the bough
breaks is [ __ ]
alright guys since you're not going to
see when the BAL Bravo please don't if
this movie's in the top 5 grossing
movies this weekend I have not done my
job here so I'm going to ask you what
your favorite fatal attraction esque
suspense drama is whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]